[Musique]
des plantations de thé à perte de vue
cela fait bientôt 4 décennies que
Enrique exploite cette parcelle de terre
appelant de montagne
[Musique]
une culture habituellement synonyme de
prospérité mais pour ce paysan rien ne
va plus depuis 10 ans
dans sa plantation un insecte ravageur
appelé hello pelletis qui mange tous les
bourgeons et qui a totalement ruiné sa
production
il est récoltait auparavant 1000 kg de
thé par mois aujourd'hui il peine à
accueillir 22
solution pour lui tout arraché pour
éventuellement ensuite recommencer mais
désemparé Henry se sent un peu seul face
à cette calamité aucune aide des
autorités ni même de ses voisins qui
craignent à leur tour d'être contaminés
et personne n'est à l'abri Paul Mexique
la prière ses dépenses
[Musique]
beaucoup sur sa plantation T pour
assurer ses vieux jours il doit toujours
lui revoir ses plans
les insectes dévastateurs sont
actuellement la principale source
d'inquiétude de palmétique mais ce n'est
pas la seule depuis quelques années dame
nature lui joue des tours
une impression confirmée par les données
météo depuis 60 ans le Kenya est en
première ligne des changements
climatiques
et les deux calamités sont intimement
reliés
oui
de change
selon une étude récente de l'ONG
question
climatiques pourraient réduire de 40%
les surfaces propices à la culture du
thé au Kenya d'ici 2050
la crise est loin d'être anecdotique de
Kenya et le premier producteur mondial
de thénoix les précieuses feuilles
constituent sa principale exportation sa
première source de devis une culture qui
fait vivre plus d'un demi million de
petits producteurs agricoles à travers
le pays alors dire qu'on s'inquiète ici
est un euphémisme
car l'impact des changements climatiques
se fait déjà sentir les clamettes
échouent
avec les 12000 petits producteurs de thé
qui fournissent l'usine de Tega à
Kericho
[Musique]
Nixon lance donc un appel
urgent pour aider les permis à s'adapter
[Musique]
seul ne lui apportera pas la retraite
tranquille tant espérer alors ils sont à
diversifier
un champ en jachère et prévoit s'acheter
des vaches laitières et comme beaucoup
ici il se désole de l'injustice
climatique car si les Africains ne
produisent que 4% des gaz à effet de
serre dans le monde ils sont les
principales victimes de leur impact